Oregon
Law enforcement
officials say a man accused
of torturing a woman
is using dating apps to avoid police.
A massive manhunt is now underway
after police found a victim last week.
They believe he bound
and beat unconscious.
CNN's Lucy Kavanagh has details,
new details
on this very disturbing story.
In Southern Oregon.
A manhunt is underway
for 36 year old
Benjamin Obadiah Foster on the run
after allegedly kidnaping
and trying to kill a woman
beating her into unconsciousness.
Police describing him
as an extremely dangerous suspect
who may attempt
to change his appearance
by shaving his beard and hair
or by changing his hair color.
The public being asked to pay
particular attention
to Foster's facial structure and eyes,
since those features are very difficult
to change.
Court documents
allege Foster
tried to kill the victim
while intentionally torturing her
and secretly
confining her in a place
where she was not likely to be found.
Police say the victim was discovered
last Tuesday in Grant's Pass, Oregon,
bound and severely beaten.
Now hospitalized in critical condition.
The suspect fleeing the scene.
I think he is
definitely a threat to others,
but I think he would be a threat
to somebody who might be friend town.
I don't think
he is
a random attacker, but I can.
Nothing's off the table
with an individual like him.
It was an absolutely disgusting scene.
Horrific scene.
I seen a lot of my career.
But some things do stick with you.
And this will
this will stay stained in my memory
for many years to come.
On Thursday, local, state
and federal authorities
raided a property about 20 miles
north of Grant's Pass,
where they seized evidence,
including Foster's 2008 Nissan Sentra.
During that search, police
arrested a 68 year old woman
for hindering prosecution
and allegedly helping foster
evade law enforcement.
Police say
Foster evaded capture
and likely received assistance
in fleeing the area
and believe
he is actively using online
dating applications
to contact unsuspecting individuals
who may be lured
into assisting
with the suspect's escape
or potentially as additional victims.
This isn't Foster's
first run-In with the law.
Court records show
he was charged in two separate cases
accusing him of attacking women
while living in Las Vegas years earlier.
In the first case,
Foster was charged
with a felony battery
constituting domestic violence.
His ex-girlfriend
testified that he had attempted
to strangle her
in a rage in 2017
after another man texted her.
He's a felon on the run.
He doesn't want to go back to prison.
He's probably willing to do anything
to stay out of prison.
While that case was still pending
in court in 2019.
Foster was charged
with felony assault, battery
and kidnaping for allegedly attacking
another woman his girlfriend at the time.
The victim told
police
Foster strangled her
to the point of unconsciousness
several times
and kept her tied up
for most of the next two weeks.
Court records show
she said she escaped
after convincing Foster to go shopping.
Foster ultimately agreed to plea deals
sentenced to a maximum
of 30 months in prison.
But given credit for the 729 days
served in the first case
the police chief in Grande's past
Oregon expressing
concern that he was set free.
My response to that question
is that am
I troubled by what I know already?
The answer is yes.
We're laser focused on capturing this man
and bringing him to justice.
The grants pass police chief
also told me that the Oregon victim
and the suspect had a prior relationship.
They knew one another.
He said
she was only found
because a friend was worried
about not having heard from her,
went to the house,
discovered her tied up and unconscious.
This friend contacted the police
and was able to immediately identify
the suspect as Benjamin Foster.
The chief
also telling me he believes
that Foster is a threat
to others who might befriend him,
that he is not a random attacker.
But added, quote,
Nothing's off the table
with an individual like him Wolf.
Horrible deed.
Lucy Cavanaugh, thank
you very, very much.